political news has dominated headlines
from the 2016 campaign into the
beginning of President Trump's
Administration The Washington Post has
been behind several of the biggest
stories they include the leaked Access
Hollywood Video and the Justice
Department's concern about Michael Flynn
the paper won a pital prize for its
investigation into Mr Trump's charitable
donations the newspaper also broke the
story about President Trump's revelation
of Highly classified information to
Russian officials in the Oval Office and
yesterday the post reported president
Trump as top intelligence officials to
deny the existence of evidence his
campaign colluded with Russia Marty
Baron is executive better to The
Washington Post and we're pleased to
have him here at this table welcome
thank you what's happened to The
Washington
Post I mean everybody's saying it's
never been better uh and you've got
remarkable reporting oh well thank you
we appreciate that we have a great uh
Team great team in The Newsroom very
proud of what they're doing uh has the
addition of a new ownership made a
difference
uh yeah uh Jeff basos is now our owner
he's owned us for about three and a half
years uh he has brought not only
financial Capital but intellectual
capital I think he's helped us to adjust
to the digital age and that's been he's
been a tremendous owner and he stood
behind us and look at today's news I
mean how does a paper cover this kind of
story well we have a tremendous team
that covers politics and policy and uh
the Washington Post of of course has
done that for a very long time and uh
this is an Administration that uh like
every Administration requires scrutiny
and we have more people probably
covering the White House now than I
think the Washington Post ever has had
have you ever seen this many leaks uh
Marty you know the president has said
has called you all fake media leaks that
the media's out to get them get him help
us understand the leak process how how
it operates at your place how can you
trust the people that are leaking the
stories to you uh well look I mean there
are a lot of people in government who
are concerned about what's happening
they feel there's information that the
public needs and deserves to know uh and
our reporters have a lot of experience
uh over the many years they've uh
cultivated uh sources in government
people who know them they they know the
sources uh these are reporters on our
staff who have a lot of experience and a
lot of expertise and so uh when people
want to talk they talk to them and don't
you double check triple check it's not
like you just rely on One Source
absolutely uh we do not rely on One
Source we always have to have extra
confirmation of anything and in many
instances the the White House said
something that was not true and then a
day later or two days later who confirms
it the president of the United States
actually confirmed our reporting Marty
this is a another stunning piece of
reporting an excellent original
reporting by The Washington Post about
the president asking his intelligence
Chiefs to deny collusion and one of the
things I read between the lines is he
asked them to do it just days after
Comey testified so there's this very
short period of time where the president
is really ramping up his activity not
only against Comey but also the
intelligence Chiefs
um and the question of leaks though just
to contextualize that people are not
calling the Washington Post giving you
information your reporters are asking
questions and then they give up
information correct yes for the most
part these are uh reporters who have a
lot of experience a lot of expertise
they've talked to a lot of people over
many many years uh they've developed
their confidence uh earned their
confidence because of the Quality
Reporting that they've done and now
people are willing to talk to them and
they trust them so let me ask you this
you're the editor what questions remain
unanswered for you oh well uh there are
a lot and that's why there's an
investigation taking place and obviously
we want to know all the same things that
the FBI is investigating that this that
the Committees in Congress are
investigating we want to know obviously
whether there was uh obstruction of
justice what constitutes obstruction of
justice we do want to know uh whether
there was collusion between uh the Trump
campaign and the Russians we can't say
for sure at the moment but to know and
yet on Friday uh your paper the post
reported that a current White House
official official is a significant
person of interest in the Russian
investigation but you didn't name who
that person is do you know who that
person is uh well we didn't name the
person I don't plan to name the person
because we haven't confirmed who that is
and when we give us the initials if we
could if we could confirm this is what
we do when we when we can't confirm we
don't report so what do you need to
confirm yeah uh we need an additional
Source or two so you do have sources
that said it's a certain person you need
that to be confirmed by other people we
need more confirmation that's about all
I can say and what does that mean
there's a a a single person who is a
person a significant Person of Interest
uh well this is a person who is subject
to investigation uh someone who the uh
the FBI and others are are looking at
very closely uh to see whether there was
a a particular connection to the
Russians that that had some influence in
in in what the Russians are you close to
confirming that person I know you said
you're still looking I really can't I
really can't say any more about it a
broader question what does this feel
like for you I mean you're in Boston uh
where they made a remarkable movie about
what happened there when you were editor
there but think about this I mean in
terms of of you've lived through a lot
of political drama has it ever been in
your feeling in your judgment anything
like this well look when I was uh coming
out of high school uh there was Nixon
and Watergate and so I wasn't in the
middle of that obviously but uh this
feels like that in many in many ways now
that's not to say that it's a Perfect
Analogy we'll have to see we need we
need to see the evidence we need to do
more investigating the uh Law
Enforcement Officers the FBI and the and
the Congressional committies need to do
more investigating and we in in the
journalism Community need to do more
investigating as well I like Charlie's
question though because I think there's
there seems to be such a competition
between the New York Times And The
Washington Post nor pointed out in the
green room it is something that the New
York Times is quoting The Washington
Post this has got to be a very
satisfying feeling for you Mar you're
very very calm and very controlled but
aren't you guys over there doing the
hoola about what is happening uh no we
we really we don't do that we're very
serious about what we do I think people
know that we're held to account like
everybody else is held to account so we
need to make sure that our information
is accurate and that takes a lot that
takes a lot of hard work with regard to
the New York Times great you know we do
not coordinate with the New York Times
we compete with the New York Times and I
think it's to the public benefit that
there are two news organizations and
other news organizations as well that
are vigorously pursuing this story I
mean that is what the meaning of the
First Amendment uh is that the press and
the public by the way is supposed to
hold their government to account uh
that's the meaning of uh self-governance
great you your speech at Penn State is a
mustre for everybody and for certainly
journalists so thank you for being here
and congrats to all the great reporters
at the post thank you much for having me
very much